♪ ♪
>> CERTAINLY LOOKS LIKE THE
RUSSIANS WERE BEHIND IT.
SOMETHING THAT SHOULD NEVER,
EVER HAPPEN, AND WE ARE TAKING
IT VERY SERIOUSLY.
>> IT IS ABSOLUTELY ATROCIOUS
AND OUTRAGEOUS WHAT RUSSIA DID
IN SALISBURY.
WE HAVE RESPONDED TO THAT.
FRANKLY, RUSSIA SHOULD GO AWAY.
IT SHOULD SHUT UP.
>> IT'S TIME TO IMPOSE SERIOUS
POLITICAL AND ECONOMIC
CONSEQUENCES ON MOSCOW.
>> THE UNITED STATES IS WORKING
TOGETHER WITH OUR ALLIES AND
PARTNERS TO ENSURE THIS KIND OF
ABHORRENT ATTACK DOESN'T HAPPEN
AGAIN.
>> WE ARE READY TO RETURN IN
PARTNERSHIP WITH THE
EUROPEAN UNION WHEN OUR
NEIGHBORS LOSE INTEREST IN
FOLLOWING AMERICAN-RUSSIAN
PHOBIC TENDENCIES.
>> Bret: BIG STEPS TODAY AND
THE TRUMP ADMINISTRATION,
SANCTIONING 19 PEOPLE, FIVE
ORGANIZATIONS.
13 INDICTED BY BOB MUELLER IN
HIS INVESTIGATION.
WHAT ABOUT THIS AND ALSO THE
RUSSIA INVESTIGATION LATEST.
LET'S BRING THE PANEL.
JONATHAN SWAN, NATIONAL
POLITICAL REPORTER FOR AXIOS.
MOLLIE HEMINGWAY, SENIOR EDITOR
AT "THE FEDERALIST."
AND OLIVIA KNOX, WASHINGTON
CORRESPONDENT.
CRITICS SAY BECAUSE 13 OF THE 19
WHO WERE SANCTIONED BY THE
ADMINISTRATION TODAY WERE FROM
THE MUELLER INVESTIGATION, THAT
THE ADMINISTRATION IS
ESSENTIALLY SAYING THAT THE
MUELLER INVESTIGATION IS A-OK.
>> THERE ARE PARTS OF THE
INVESTIGATION I THINK NOBODY HAS
A PROBLEM WITH.
THE WHOLE IDEA ABOUT
INVESTIGATION IS TO LOOK INTO
MEDDLING IN THE U.S. ELECTION.
THE 13 INDICTMENTS HAD
EVERYTHING TO DO WITH MEDDLING.
WHERE PEOPLE ARE CONCERNED ARE
WHEN MUELLER GOES FAR AFIELD
FROM THE ELECTION AND THE NARROW
CONFINES PEOPLE UNDERSTAND AS
INVESTIGATE.
IF PEOPLE MET OLD, THEY SHOULD
BE HELD ACCOUNTABLE.
NOT JUST BY CHARGING THEM WITH
THE CRIME NOBODY WILL EVER SEE
THEM TAKE HER SPOTS BILLED FOR.
SANCTIONS OR SOMETHING LIKE
THAT.
>> Bret: IS THIS THE NEW TAKE
ON RUSSIA ON STEPPING UP, WHAT
NIKKI HALEY SAID AT THE U.N.,
WHAT WE ARE SEEING TODAY?
AND THE REVELATION OF THE CYBER
ATTACKS ON U.S. INFRASTRUCTURE,
INCLUDING THE ELECTRICAL GRID.
>> TRUMP'S INSTINCTS HAVE ALWAYS
BEEN STRONG ON RUSSIA.
THEY ARE KEY TO SOLVING THE
MIDDLE EAST PROBLEM, A GOOD
RELATIONSHIP WITH RUSSIA.
BUT EVIDENCE UPON EVIDENCE UPON
EVIDENCE HAS MAYBE NOT TOTALLY
CHANGED HIS MIND BUT AT LEAST
MOVED THEM AWAY FROM WHERE HE
WAS MAYBE SIX MONTHS AGO.
CERTAINLY THE TEAM AROUND HIM
ARE FAIRLY HAWKISH, PARTICULARLY
NIKKI HAWKISH.
>> Bret: HERE IS SARAH SANDERS
TODAY.
>> SOMETHING THAT RUSSIA IS
GOING TO HAVE TO DECIDE WHETHER
THEY WILL WANT -- THEY WANT TO
BE A GOOD ACTOR OR BAD ACTOR.
YOU CAN SEE FROM THE ACTIONS
WE'VE TAKEN, WE ARE GOING TO BE
TOUGH ON RUSSIA UNTIL THEY
DECIDE TO CHANGE THEIR BEHAVIOR.
>> IT'S NOTABLE BUT NOT HUGE.
A LOT OF THE PEOPLE WHO WERE
ANNOUNCED TODAY WERE ALREADY
UNDER AMERICAN SANCTIONS.
UNDER OBAMA AND AN EARLIER WAVE
OF TRUMP SANCTIONS.
THE LETTER THAT ACCOMPANIED IT,
IT LEAVES THE ELECTION MEDDLING
AND VLADIMIR PUTIN'S DOORSTEP.
THE MAIN MILITARY INTELLIGENCE
SERVICE WAS DIRECTLY INVOLVED,
THAT'S IMPORTANT.
THE DECISION TO REVEAL THIS
INFRASTRUCTURE ATTACK, THAT'S
GOING TO GET A LOT OF
WELL-DESERVED HEADLINE.
IT'S WORRISOME.
THEY APPARENTLY HAD THE ABILITY
TO TURN THINGS ON AND OFF.
THEN THE ATTRIBUTION AND
PUNISHMENT FOR THE MALWARE THAT
RACED THROUGH EUROPE I DID TENS
OF BILLIONS OF DOLLARS IN
DAMAGE.
YOU'RE SEEING A RHETORICAL
ESCALATION FROM THE
ADMINISTRATION.
WE HAVE YET TO SEE THE SAME
ESCALATION IN THE RHETORIC FROM
THE PRESIDENT.
>> Bret: "NEW YORK TIMES" HAD
A PIECE TODAY ABOUT THE MUELLER
INVESTIGATION SAYING THAT
MUELLER HAS SUBPOENAED THE TRUMP
ORGANIZATION, DEMANDING
DOCUMENTS.
MR. MUELLER ORDERED THE TRUMP
ORGANIZATION TO HAND OVER ALL
RECORDS RELATED TO RUSSIA AND
OTHER TOPICS.
TRUMP ORGANIZATION HAS SAID IT
NEVER HAD REAL ESTATE HOLDINGS
IN RUSSIA.
WITNESSES INTERVIEWED BY
MR. MUELLER HAVE BEEN ASKED
ABOUT A POSSIBLE REAL ESTATE
DEAL IN MOSCOW.
THE TRUMP ORGANIZATION MEANTIME
IS SAYING THEY HAVE BEEN
COOPERATING.
AND THAT THEY HAVE BEEN HANDING
OVER DOCUMENTS.
WHY A SUBPOENA QUESTION!
COOPERATION CAN GO ALONG WITH A
SUBPOENA.
THE INVESTIGATION MIGHT WANT TO
BE VERY PARTICULAR ABOUT WHAT
THEY'RE LOOKING FOR TO MAKE SURE
THEY GET EVERYTHING, NOT JUST
HAVING IT BE A SHARED THERE IS A
POLITICAL QUESTION HERE THAT WE
HAVE BEEN SPENDING A LOT OF TIME
INVESTIGATING COLLUSION WITH
RUSSIA.
WHETHER THE TRUMP ORGANIZATION
COLLUDED WITH RUSSIA TO STEAL AN
ELECTION.
I'M NOT SURE IF THERE IS A
POLITICAL APPETITE TO LOOK FOR A
CRIME UNTIL YOU FIND ONE.
THAT'S HOW YOU DO THINGS IN
RUSSIA MAY BE.
NOT HOW YOU DO THINGS IN AMERICA
NOT HOW YOU DO THINGS IN AMERIC
AMERICA.
>> Bret: YOU HEARD EARLIER IN
THE INTERVIEWS, SENATORS
GRASSLEY AND GRAHAM CALLING FOR
ANOTHER SPECIAL COUNSEL.
>> YEAH.
I DON'T KNOW THE CHANCES OF THAT
HAPPENING BUT I THINK THE MOST
SIGNIFICANT THING ABOUT THIS
STORY IS THE STORY ITSELF AND
HOW THE PRESIDENT OF THE
UNITED STATES WILL REACT TO IT.
YES, MAYBE PERHAPS THIS
COOPERATION HAS BEEN GOING ON
QUIETLY, BUT WE KNOW THAT WHEN
THE PRESIDENT SEES THESE STORIES
ON TELEVISION, IF YOU WERE GOING
TO WRITE A STORY TO GET UNDER
HIS SKIN, YOU WILL WRITE THAT
STORY.
THE STORY THAT MUELLER IS
DELVING INTO.
TRUMP SET ON THE RECORD TO
"THE NEW YORK TIMES" THAT THAT
WOULD BE A RED LINE, GOING INTO
BUSINESS DEALING.
I THINK THE MOST INTERESTING
THING IS THE ALCHEMY THAT
CREATES.
>> THERE'S ALSO THE ISSUE THAT
THIS INVESTIGATION BEGAN TO LOOK
INTO COLLUSION.
WE HAVE THESE CONGRESSIONAL
INVESTIGATIONS.
THEY DON'T FIND COLLUSION BUT
WHAT THEY DO FIND --
IF ANYONE HAS INFORMATION ON
COLLUSION, IT WILL BE GREAT TO
GET IT OUT.
BUT WHAT YOU FOUND OUT WAS THAT
THERE WERE PROBLEMS AT THE FBI
AND DEPARTMENT OF JUSTICE.
THERE HAVE BEEN CRIMINAL LEAKS.
FISA ABUSE ANOTHER PROBLEMS.
WE CAN'T EXPECT THE FBI AND
DEPARTMENT OF JUSTICE TO
INVESTIGATE THEMSELVES.
WHETHER OR NOT MEDIA PEOPLE CARE
ABOUT THE SCANDAL OF THE
CENTURY, THE AMERICAN PEOPLE
NEED ANSWERS FOR THE PROBLEMS AT
THE FBI AND APARTMENT OF JUSTICE
THE FBI AND APARTMENT OF JUSTIC
JUSTICE.
I DON'T SEE HOW ELSE YOU RESTORE
THE ABILITY OF THESE AGENCIES
AND LETS YOU HAVE SOMEONE TRULY
INDEPENDENT WHO CAN INVESTIGATE.
>> Bret: I WANT TO TURN WHAT
THE PRESIDENT SAID, THE
STORIES OF A BIG SHAKE-UP IN THE
WHITE HOUSE ARE OVERWRITTEN,
OVER EXAGGERATED, FAKE NEWS,
WHATEVER YOU WANT TO CALL IT.
CLEARLY HE IS LOOKING AT MAKING
OTHER MOVES.
WE DON'T KNOW WHEN AND HOW BIG.
>> THE PRESIDENT FLATLY DENIED,
CALLED IT FAKE NEWS, WHEN THERE
WERE REPORTS HE WAS LOOKING TO
REPLACE REX TILLERSON WITH MIKE
POMPEO WHICH IS EXACTLY WHAT HAS
HAPPENED.
IT'S TRUE THAT SOMETIMES THE
PRESIDENT WILL REACH OUT TO
ADVISORS OUTSIDE THE WHITE HOUSE
AND TELL HIM, WHAT DO YOU THINK
WITH SO-AND-SO?
THAT TRANSLATES INTO A LOT OF
THE STORIES THAT THE PRESIDENT
IS CONSIDERING DUMPING THE
FOLLOWING PEOPLE.
WE HAVE HAD ENOUGH CHAOS AT THIS
POINT THAT THERE IS NO REASON TO
THINK THERE'S NOT MORE COMING.
>> Bret: DEAL BUY THAT
QUESTION!
IF YOU GO TO THE WHITE HOUSE NOW
AND SAY I HAVE REPORTING THAT
H.R. MCMASTER IS ON HIS WAY OUT,
YOU WOULD NOT GET A LOT OF
PUSHBACK.
THE COMMON ACCEPTANCE WITHIN THE
WHITE HOUSE THAT AT SOME POINT
PROBABLY IN THE FAIRLY NEAR
FUTURE, HE'S GONE.
BUT NOBODY IS OF 2 HOURS AGO
KNEW WHEN THAT WAS GOING TO
HAPPEN AND WHO IS GOING TO
REPLACE HIM.
I STILL HAVEN'T WRITTEN THE
H.R. MCMASTER STORY IS GONE
BECAUSE IT'S BEEN WRITTEN EVERY
WEEK FOR EIGHT MONTHS.
AT SOME POINT IT WILL BE
CORRECT.
I BELIEVE IT WILL BE CORRECT
FAIRLY SOON.
BUT WHEN THE PRESIDENT TALKS